hi there bonsoir the young I'm in leo
we've had a fabulous time my wife Carmen
and I about these nine euro reading
glasses I really like them um fabulous
really we ate well the local Liam food
with heavy cream and lots of sausages a
little heavy for us lots of poor boo
Koos everywhere so he went to two
different Buffy Nepal boo Koos we stayed
away from his restaurant where it's like
a hundred and fifty euros for the
evening per person a couple of quick
comments first of all Leo is a lovely
city and this apartment we're staying in
i booked it through airbnb the host
Sergei Tom and Lucy is tremendous a nice
small little apartment cozy we can have
our coffee here in the morning and it's
relaxing to come back to the only
inconvenience that is five flights of
stairs like five stories up a very
narrow winding circular staircase so
it's a bit of exercise to get up here
which is fine because we eat so much we
got to do something to work off the
calories but it's lovely the two rivers
here the soul and the hoenn and lots
clean and and lots of nice places to
visit and shops and restaurants and
beautiful squares and stuff we really
really really enjoyed it it's my first
real stay in Leo I think as a student I
might have hitched hiked through here I
think one evening I had to help a
trucker unload his fruit and vegetable
crates at the market at four in the
morning that was my previous
recollection of Leon before I hitchhike
on to another I was where I was living
meetups we're having more evening dinner
at the carpenters arms in laga horn
that's pronounced in Wales and then it
now looks like I'm going to be staying
in bath a little longer because my son
and my granddaughter coming up to spend
time with those so maybe the meet up in
London should be between christmas and
new year if people have the time and ah
there's a Russian conference I'm going
to be participating in Russian a
conference yo just 20 budu test which
conferencia not easy Jenna and visca
value Zika is it is a contact it can be
a bit tough to get my polish out of my
brain and speak Russian I will leave a
link w silk una oppa Sonia yes a bridge
a chair please come and listen if you're
interested you can see the link in the
description and I can have to spend the
next few days listening to Russian to
get my Russian back up to snuff so that
I can have a conference in Russian
anyway thank you merci and viento for
those of you who are planning to join me
in a meadow by